let's go with Marie's Ashley and a
special guest we are with Jill Beth
Hauser who is the CEO of Colliers
International the sponsor of the Paris
grand chest tour and Jill welcome to the
show you are here in Zagreb why not in
Paris why are you here I'm here
just support Maksim because Maxime is
getting competition now he is playing
today with Vishy Anand and I'm
supporting him I tried to follow him on
the tour let's say five or six times a
year and I really appreciate competition
and especially hands ago which is a nice
City and very nice event you mentioned
it's United Pauline as a fan you
actually sponsor him as well yeah I need
to confess that I'm sponsor of Maxime
since 10 years it's it's a very tight
relationship that we have been built
together and I'm happy and proud from
where he came from and where is now in
terms of level that's really amazing in
fact to watch him rise to the elite of
world chess that there must have been
just a stunning thing to see his
development what made you want to
sponsor him in the first place well it
has been a tremendous adventure and not
just we are not just talking about
competition but he became a great man
and a good friend of mine and we had the
good and bad let's say payouts but so
far is in the shape and he's trying his
best in order to get to the next level
but you know Magnus is so strong that it
will be to be home but let's say we try
yes of course it's a small problem this
guy magnus carlsen and that everybody
has to overcome you have been sponsoring
your company has been sponsoring now the
paris we're at chester assembly the
fourth year
yes you got it on television II with
Vivendi yes partnering with you yeah
what's been the push like trying to get
the French audience to embrace yes okay
so France is a great chess country we
had a good history in chess but we
didn't have any events since 20 years
and four years ago the conscious to
approach me and say let's build a
conscious tool even in Paris which was a
great occasion to see all the top 10
superstars in chess in in price so we
created that four years ago I tried to
partner with Vivint in order to promote
this event which is a big event in in
price or we started 2016 this year it
will be the fourth event it has been the
great success in terms of audience not
only people watching TV but getting in
touch with Internet we had tremendous
numbers so it's it's the first times
once again since 20 years that we have
great chess events in in price and
people like it and we are trying to
establish that on the long term
perspective friends deserve to have a
great event advice is a great city I
think the players like to come there I
can't wait and you have been
participating too - that so - you know
that it's good events with great
atmosphere and not going to be a great
event July 22nd August 2nd by by the way
July 26th
so I second for the fans who were very
prepared to do that event we always love
being in Paris no question about it and
then there's always the program now
people may not know that you yourself
are an avid chess player very good chess
player even though you might argue
that's so great but you you partnered
with Garry Kasparov in one of these
parameters tell us what it's like
because I know from watching Gary in st.
Louis that can't be easy to be his
tandem chess partner making moves
without
getting any suggestions from him that's
gotta be a lot of pressure okay so I
need to confess that I have a different
experience in in the poem most of the
time I play with with Maxim much more
easy for for me in terms of let's say in
terms of tension in terms of fun as well
a guy is a great competitor so when you
play with Gary you want to do your best
but sometimes your best is not
sufficient to get his recognition so you
feel that tension and that provide you
some let's say weaknesses and you are
confused and and you don't play even a
rich you pay very badly and look to you
and you almost dead you feel just eat it
so it was not an outstanding experience
but it was a very funny expense
I would I could say that to my
grandchildren in 20 years from now
that's a great story I think all of us
would feel the same way compression
Gargas mara well thanks so much for
joining us and thanks for being such a
wonderful sponsor for the grand chest or
who really appreciate everything that
you're doing thank you voice your what
would I do thank you thank you Jim Pat
Hauser CEO of Colliers International
this was a great partner for chess we
need more folks like this as he brings
together this wonderful event in Paris
make sure you check it out again July 26
through all the second thank you thank
you for all of your sponsorship